إذا كان هذا التنظيم الإرهابي يسمى إرهاب حزب العمال الكردستاني
هي منظمة إرهابية
ليس فقط لتركيا ولكن أيضا للسويد.
للإضرار بالمصالح الوطنية
كيفية اختيار البحر الذي يعمل
يبذل قصارى جهده ليصبح عضوا.
[موسيقى]
في الواقع رئيس البلدية وسفيرنا
كانوا معًا في مكان ما و
عندما طلب اللحم لدينا على الفور ، البلدية
سيدي الرئيس ، لم يكن هناك شيء من هذا القبيل على الإطلاق.
قال عندما سألنا السلطات
قالوا ليس لديهم أخبار ولكن
اليوم الشرطة السويدية
قال ما حدث
أ
هل أنت جندي
توماتيلو
أثناء الولادة يوجد سلاح أيضا منشفة
يمكن أن ننظر حبوب مع الدول الورقية
الضوء الفائق مكسور تعال أحب يدك
مرحاضك
[موسيقى]
عصير أو شيء من هذا القبيل
إنه بالتأكيد يستحق الحياة بدافع سيء
لا أوصي به ، أليس كذلك؟ Merdini في جولة. لماذا؟
ماذا ايضا
اشترك